[Música]
josephine baker tenía dos amores pero
sobre todo una vida impresionante
eso es lo que nos cuenta josephine ve en
el escenario el viaje de una chica de
missouri nacida en la pobreza que se
convirtió en una estrella mundial una
mujer libre y valiente
[Música]
josephine baker es la libertad encarnada
es la provocación la belleza y la gracia
de la ley
pero ella también encarna el compromiso
junio 40 la josephine del music-hall
conquistó a francia pero también buscó
ayudar a liberarla por lo que entró en
la resistencia de una gran lucha ahora
de la residencia francesa de ella misma
lo decía yo ponía microfilmes en donde
articula si en mi sujetador mayor mi
habitación estaba abierta toda la
información no existía porque tenía en
la cabeza una única cosa
es decir
ayudará a francés de fos
fue recompensada por ello y obtuvo
varias medallas y estas medallas las
llevó a washington para seguir a martin
luther king en su lucha por los derechos
de los afroamericanos
[Música]
esta lucha contra el racismo la siguió
haciendo desde su casa en el campo y con
ternura formó una familia de niños
adoptados huérfanos de todas partes del
mundo y junto a jon cloud brain de dónde
vienes de argelia 50 años después
brágimo recuerda esta educación peculiar
allí me estaba dando tercero es el
séptimo de los doce hijos de josephine
baker a los que ella llamaba su tribu
arcoiris
era una familia multiétnica y
multicultural y mickey pero que fue
criada unida y al mismo tiempo sólo para
demostrar al mundo entero que cuando se
crían a los niños juntos es un ideal de
fraternidad universal posible y no
utópico un ideal del fatídico universal
es posible no para youtube
es esta utopía y este espíritu de
resistencia que ahora llevan a josephine
baker al panteón
[Música]